The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high-quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
LING REN: All right.
Let's get started.
Today's topic would be
distributed algorithms.
We will look at
two new algorithms.
But they are similar to what
you have seen in the lectures.
So it will also be a review
of some concepts in lectures.
So our first example
would be, again,
[INAUDIBLE], the
simplest example.
But this time, the network
and topology would be a ring.
So in the lectures,
the example we see
is a click, meaning they
are fully connected.
Right.
Every node can talk
to every other node.
There, if you remember,
our solution for everyone
to generate a UID
or a random number.
And if you are the maximum, then
you output, you're the leader
You can do that because, yeah,
you are connected to everybody.
So you immediately know
what random number everybody
generates.
And you can compare whether
you are the largest.
Now, the idea is the
same if we have a ring.
So you want everyone to
generate a ID or random number.
I'll just say ID from now on.
And you want to collect
everyone else ID
so that you know
whether your ID is
the largest among all of them.
OK.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
LING REN: Pardon?
LING REN: OK.
The question is where did
the comparison happen?
So we first need
some way to pass
the numbers around
such that everyone
has everyone else's number.
Right.
You have the number
of everyone, then
you can compare whether
the largest equals yours.
OK.
If the largest equals
yours, then you
know you are the largest.
And you're going to
output, I'm the leader.
OK.
So the difficulty is just
how to pass the numbers
around so that everyone
sees everyone else's number.
Any ideas?
Simple solution.
Well, there's not
much you can do.
You are just connect to your
two neighbors, the left one
and the right one.
So how do you propagate
the information?
Go ahead.
AUDIENCE: You can take
the maximum of your ID
and neighbor's IDs and
kind of broadcast that.
LING REN: OK.
So what does
broadcast mean here?
AUDIENCE: Like
tell your neighbors
what the largest of
your value [INAUDIBLE]
LING REN: OK.
And yes.
Let me call them A, B, C, E,
F. Then, yes, C can tell D
or can tell B, but
how does C tell E?
AUDIENCE: It waited around to
I guess propagate the maximum.
LING REN: Yep.
So it would be just,
say, everyone talks
to its right neighbor.
And then B has A's IDs, C
these B's ID, D has C's ID,
and then continue and
pass around next time.
So just to make
it perfect clear.
Say they generate some
random IDs that's 5, 10, 20.
And then in the next round,
A would send its ID to B, B
would send its ID to C,
C would send its ID to D.
And in the next round, B would
pass this information along
to C. And C would pass
the information to D.
And just continue.
And eventually everyone will
have everyone else's ID.
So how many rounds do we need?
If they are in
nodes in the system.
AUDIENCE: I think probably
in just one direction or two
neighbors.
LING REN: I think you
can do it either way.
If you propagate both ways,
it probably 2x faster, yeah.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
LING REN: Yeah, correct.
It's just O(n).
But to keep it simple,
let's say we just
propagate in one direction.
That's also fine.
Still O(n).
So how many messages
are sent in total?
AUDIENCE: n squared.
LING REN: Pardon?
LING REN: n squared.
Yep.
Is that obvious to everyone?
OK.
Give an explanation.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, at
each round everyone
sends a message
to its neighbors.
LING REN: Yeah.
Yeah.
Every round, everyone
sends a message.
Or you can think of every
message as propagated n times.
And there are n
messages in total.
OK.
Yeah.
That's definitely a solution.
Well, you can imagine, it's
probably the naive solution.
And can we do better than that?
AUDIENCE: In this case,
are we assuming they
know that there are n of them?
LING REN: OK.
Good question.
So if they know
there are n of them,
yep, then they know
how to terminate.
So your question is how
to terminate, right?
If they don't, eventually
you will receive your own ID
on the other side.
If we keep sending
left, eventually you
will receive it
on the left port.
And, yeah, that's an
indication of termination.
Question?
AUDIENCE: Are we
assuming the trajectory
that these are unique?
LING REN: Yeah.
We usually assume that, yeah.
Either it's a unique
user-- sorry, UID.
What does U stand
for by the way?
Or if you generate random
numbers in a large range,
it's very unlikely
that they collide.
OK.
So can we do better than that?
You have some idea?
AUDIENCE: Once
something [INAUDIBLE]
where you only pass it
to the one that's bigger.
LING REN: Hm-mm.
OK.
I think you have two ideas.
And binary search, we'll
see how that works later.
So you said only forward
something that's larger?
AUDIENCE: Yeah, like only
forward things are larger.
LING REN: OK, yeah,
that's on the right track.
So one obvious
thing we can do is
that so we actually don't care
what all the IDs are, right.
We only care whether a
certain ID's the largest.
So for example, in this case,
when A send its ID 5 to B,
B knows this 5
won't be the leader.
All right.
Because 5 is too small.
It's even smaller than his ID.
So we can choose to
drop this message.
There's no point in passing
that message further.
Same thing for this message.
C knows that 10 is too small.
And it doesn't have
to pass it along.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
LING REN: Oh, the ID?
It's just the integer each
node chooses at random.
See.
Yeah, the only purpose of
the ID is to break symmetry.
So, yeah.
Like we have seen the lecture,
if they don't do this,
if they don't have
any unique identifier,
they won't be able
to select the leader.
And when they have
a unique number,
then they can select, yeah,
the largest one or smallest
one in some way.
OK.
Does this optimization
make sense?
We can cut [INAUDIBLE]
messages that
have no chance of
becoming the leader.
AUDIENCE: What is the
upper bound of it?
Is it still n squared?
LING REN: Correct.
Yeah.
That's a very good question and
very good answer, by the way.
But how effective is this?
Well in average case, we may
be able to drop some messages.
But there pathological
case where it actually
doesn't help at all.
Say this is the ID we choose.
Then when there's
20, it send around.
B cannot drop it.
Right, because it
may be the largest.
And when this 10 is sent
to C, C cannot drop it.
And when 20 comes along,
it also cannot drop it.
So no node can drop any message.
Its worst case is
still n square.
OK.
So let's think about the
binary search equivalent, yeah,
or how to binary
search in this case.
AUDIENCE: So binary
is [INAUDIBLE] what?
LING REN: Yeah, good question.
It's not very obvious
binary searching to what.
I Yeah, just some
binary idea that
will give us a n log end bound.
So actually this is
the better logarithm.
But once you have a
log n, you can probably
get-- OK, go ahead.
AUDIENCE: How about
kind of merging,
like instead of finding
the [INAUDIBLE],
finding like log maximum,
then [INAUDIBLE].
LING REN: Yeah.
That's on the right track, yeah.
AUDIENCE: Like clusters
of some [INAUDIBLE].
LING REN: Yeah.
That's definitely
the right idea.
Let's detail it a little bit.
How do you carry it out?
Hm-mm.
AUDIENCE: Divide the two parts.
Like kind of the [INAUDIBLE].
LING REN: And, OK,
so then it's let
them select their leader
respectively and compare
which one is larger.
It's interesting thought.
AUDIENCE: First,
for example, A, B
finds the maximum
between these two,
the C, D finds the maximum
E [INAUDIBLE] maximum.
Kind of merging, considering
them as one node.
LING REN: I think
the first difficulty
I see is that if
you cut it by half,
it's no longer a ring, right.
AUDIENCE: Also they can't
cut themselves in half.
LING REN: Yeah.
Yeah.
Correct.
Yeah, yeah.
Yeah, it's definitely
not an easy problem, not
a easy algorithm.
And the idea is to, well,
you had the right idea.
That we want to--
what's the word?
Let the weak candidates
shut up early.
So what I mean by that is say
we have several round, so this B
and A and C. We will that B
only propagate to A and C first.
If B is the local maximum
among A, B, C, then
B will try to talk further.
Increase its range.
If B is not the local maximum
of A, B, C, then, yeah,
it can be quiet.
Doesn't need to send
messages anymore.
If B succeeds in the
next round, then you
go further increase its range
to try to talk to more people.
OK.
So how does it work in detail?
Well so in round I,
we will let a node
send this message up
to 2 raised to I hops.
In this case, is 1 and in
next round is 2 and then 4.
If at any point some mode
like along this range
decides that you are
not the local maximum,
then they will reply
that, yeah, you no longer
need to send messages anymore.
If this message successfully
reaches this endpoint
that 2 raised to I hops,
then this guy will respond.
And this guy, if it still thinks
you are the local maximum,
then it will respond the message
while saying, yeah, continue.
OK.
And if the sender receives the
continue message on both sides,
then they it continue
into the next round.
Otherwise, it will go inactive.
Is the algorithm clear?
AUDIENCE: If the problem
reaches the next maximum,
like next the node each
has to send a message.
LING REN: Say that again.
AUDIENCE: Like after receiving
like don't sending it,
like do you have to
choose one node, which
has to send the message?
LING REN: Oh, OK.
In the first round, everyone
send their messages.
OK.
Then some of them
will go inactive
because they learn
they are not maximum.
And the remaining,
the surviving ones,
will, yeah, continue
sending messages.
And then, yeah, half
of them probably
will die in the next round.
And the surviving ones
keep sending messages.
Make sense?
AUDIENCE: How do you
return messages through I?
Like if you [INAUDIBLE] its
neighbor and not the node that
do either.
LING REN: Yeah.
So we will send the
message of this form,
say, well, some message.
And then we will send the
hop and the direction,
either left or right.
And this hop will
initially be set
to 2 raised to I,
the number of round.
Then when this guy
receives the message,
it will increment the hop
count and pass it along.
And every node when
forwarding the message
will decrease the that h by 1.
And finally when it reaches
here, that number becomes 0.
And when a node sees a
message with 0 hop count,
it's going to reverse it, send
it in the other direction.
And, again, set it
back to 2 raised to I.
This message I should say ID.
And at certain
point, a certain node
may decide this ID's too small.
It doesn't have a chance.
Then the I can directly send
it in the opposite direction,
replying a message saying,
yeah, you are too small.
OK.
So any more questions
on the algorithm itself?
If not, what's the next step?
AUDIENCE: Time.
LING REN: Yeah, time complexity.
I already claimed it's n log n.
Is it?
This is round.
This is message.
This is also message complexity.
OK.
So why is it n log n?
AUDIENCE: The log n [INAUDIBLE].
LING REN: Hm-mm.
So we have a certain
number of rounds.
So how many rounds do we have?
AUDIENCE: Two.
LING REN: Yeah, maybe.
But, yeah, I'll just say log n.
OK.
Because you are increasing
your hop length.
And we're going to compute
like how many nodes are still
active each around and how many
messages are sent in the round.
So, well, the number
of nodes active
will just be this number
if we start from 0.
Why?
Because the first time
everyone is active.
In the next time, only 1/3
of them will be active.
But we said we are conservative
here at we put 1/2.
Right.
Next round is actually 1/5.
If it's local maximum,
it means like these two
and those two will go inactive.
But we put this
as a upper bound.
So this is the number of
nodes that are still active.
And they will send the
message up to this many hops.
OK.
And there are two directions.
And you send a message back.
And then, yeah-- sorry,
send the message forward
and someone will reply.
But in the end, this is n log n.
Yeah, and I think
I got 8n log n.
So my recitation note says
it's 4 log n, not entirely sure
what's going on.
Yeah.
But you can double check
whether this is correct
or the recitation
note is correct.
AUDIENCE: What is I again?
LING REN: I's the number
of round in the I-th round.
Yeah.
This many nodes
are still active.
And each of them will send
a message of this many hops.
And I didn't mention
whether the network
is synchronous or asynchronous.
And it turns out
it doesn't care.
Some of them can work for both
synchronous and asynchronous.
Apparently, it works for
synchronous networks.
If it's asynchronous,
then what changes
is that different nodes
are in different rounds.
A certain node may be far
ahead than the others.
But it's fine.
Eventually, they will converge
to the correct result. OK.
So let's look at
the second problem.
Well, problem's
defined even simpler.
We just want to count how
many nodes are out there.
We want the algorithm to
work both synchronously and
asynchronously.
By that I just mean
we have a network.
Well, say you have a
lot of nodes after that.
Just want to count how
many nodes are there
in this network.
So I'll give you, say, one
minutes to let's first come up
with a high-level plan.
Is the problem clear?
AUDIENCE: In the worst
case, [INAUDIBLE].
The worst case.
LING REN: OK.
I haven't defined that.
Let's not worry about
complexity now for now.
The complexity will
depend on number of nodes
and the number of
edges, E. Let's just
get it functionally correct.
OK.
Anyone share a
high-level strategy?
Go ahead.
AUDIENCE: So each
node will start
like IDs of the other
devices [INAUDIBLE].
So basically like it's going
to send propagates [INAUDIBLE]
sets of each node.
LING REN: On what edge?
AUDIENCE: Furthest one.
LING REN: Yeah.
It wasn't on both edges?
AUDIENCE: Itself first.
LING REN: OK.
So then maybe send the 1 here
and send the 1 here there.
Then this node will think it
has a children, it as a child,
right, which is this one.
Let's just say this
is the entire network.
And what message does
it send to this guy?
AUDIENCE: Reinforced it.
LING REN: Well, you
probably need send two here
because you have one and this
is possibly its child, right.
But then we're double
counting this node.
See the problem?
AUDIENCE: Do nodes have
their IDs, like unique IDs?
LING REN: Oh, yeah.
They have their IDs.
AUDIENCE: We can't send
the IDs instead of the IDs
through the end node.
LING REN: OK.
We are going to
send all the IDs.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, neighbors.
And after n steps, it's going
to have the [INAUDIBLE].
LING REN: OK.
Yeah, that's an
interesting thought.
And then you may
still need the root.
And that will have
everyone's ID.
And then see how many
unique I's are there.
OK.
Interesting.
Does this algorithm work?
Yeah, I don't see any problem.
OK.
But let me still repeat
what our algorithm
is because it's closer
to what's in the lecture.
So we're going to find a
spanning tree of this network.
A spanning tree
means, well, like I
have to cut one of these edges.
If I have a tree, then I
can have every child report
to its parent.
Like how many offsprings,
including myself do I have.
And this node will sum
up all its children
and report to its parent.
Does everyone get that?
So first, we'll find
a spanning tree.
And second, we'll have
child reports to parent.
AUDIENCE: How can we
find the spanning tree?
LING REN: Good question.
So in the lecture, we
have seen algorithm
that find BFS spanning tree
for synchronous networks.
OK.
This is review of the lecture.
How does it work?
Each node will, say, we
need to first choose a root.
And our root will just send
a message to its neighbor
and, yeah, saying, you are
my child, you are my child,
you are my child.
And then every node upon
receiving this message
from the parent will
search among its neighbors.
All right.
So the neighbors that
haven't got a parent
will acknowledge this
sender as the parent.
OK.
That's a little messy.
So this node will
search to the leaf node.
But then it will also try
to search for this guy.
But this guy already had
a parent, then, yeah,
it will say I already got a
parent and blah, blah, blah.
This will give us a
BFS spanning tree.
What does it mean?
It's a spanning
tree found by BFS.
Does it work for
asynchronous network?
Go ahead.
AUDIENCE: This version doesn't.
But there's a
different version that
contains an edge for
relaxation technique.
LING REN: Yeah.
Correct.
And so why does this version not
work for a synchronous network?
AUDIENCE: Because
different nodes
can be on a different
round number
so that a longer path could
end up going to the node even.
LING REN: Yeah, exactly.
So let me give a
concrete example.
What does asynchronous
network mean?
Is that, well, messages
travel at different speed.
Say this link for some
reason is temporarily down.
And this node doesn't receive
the message from the root.
And then this message
travels very fast.
And this message also
So this message may
reach this node earlier.
And then this node will think
of it as a child of this node.
OK.
And then this message
comes along, finally.
But this node says, yeah,
I already have a parent.
And I'm going to reject you.
AUDIENCE: So it still
makes a spanning tree?
LING REN: Yes.
Good point.
This is not a BFS spanning tree
but it's still a spanning tree.
All right.
So in our problem, we're
totally fine with it.
Yeah.
But you do have to know if
you really want a BFS spanning
tree in an asynchronous
network, then
you have to like record the
distance and do the relaxation
and so on and so forth.
OK.
So we will just use this
algorithm, the BFS spanning
tree algorithm, just
run it asynchronously.
It doesn't find the
BFS spanning tree
but it finds some spanning tree.
OK.
How does this algorithm work?
We will have several variables.
The first one is parent.
We will initialize to
this undefined single.
OK.
Then every node will pass
around this search message.
I'll use a slightly
more shorthand notation
than from the lecture.
OK.
Let's say the code I
wrote is for a process u.
OK.
If we receive a message,
a search message, from v
to u, that means u-- sorry, v
is trying to become a parent.
OK.
And if I do not
have a parent yet,
I should set the
parent to v. OK.
So what's the next step?
Now, we got this search
message from our parent.
And we have to pass it along.
AUDIENCE: Should we
send it to the like
add your child [INAUDIBLE].
LING REN: Oh, yeah.
Great.
Yeah, we first need to
respond by saying, OK,
I'll use a shorter notation.
Send these a cue that
that's the message that will
be sent to v at some point.
The message we send is parent 1.
Parent 2.
This is a response to v saying,
yeah, you are my parent.
OK.
Then else, we also have to
respond by saying parent 0.
You are not my parent because I
already got some other parent.
OK.
Missing a step here.
If we receive a search message.
Go ahead.
AUDIENCE: We send messages
to all the other nodes.
LING REN: Yeah.
We need to pass it to all
my potential children.
So I use this comma u,
meaning the neighbors of u.
And then I'll send
them a message.
What message?
Search.
OK.
So, well, naturally since
we have a search message
and we know how to
deal with it, now we
are sending this parent message
with better deal with it.
Right.
So then the next
chunk of code should
be if we receive this parent
message, I'll say parent b,
meaning this message comes
with either true or false.
I received this message
from some node w.
OK.
I'm still u here.
Because I just send all
the message to all the w's,
to all my neighbors, and they
should give me a response.
OK.
If b is 1 that means
this particular w
take me as its parent.
Make sense?
OK.
So I'd better have a
list of my children.
I want to keep track of that.
How?
We will create a new
variable for children.
It's going to be
initialized to what?
Yeah, empty set.
And now if this b
is 1, then I'm going
to put w in this children list.
OK.
I'm leaving some space
here because our root
should be slightly different.
So every other node will
send search messages
when it receive
a search message.
We need someone to initiate.
Make sense?
So if u equals root,
we say the root is v0.
So two things should happen.
First, we should set its
parent to some special value.
Just say root.
And then I should copy
this blob of code to here.
OK.
It's a little crowded but
I hope it's still legible.
OK.
This is already almost
the correct algorithm,
except that we don't
know how to terminate.
If we wait long
enough, then everyone
will receive all the responses
and everyone will know
its parent and this child list.
But how do we terminate?
AUDIENCE: After n rounds.
LING REN: Yeah, that's one
way to do, after n rounds.
But the whole point is we
are trying to find what n is.
We don't know how
many nodes are there.
AUDIENCE: If we receive
reject for all, [INAUDIBLE].
LING REN: Say again.
AUDIENCE: For all the search,
if we receive a reject.
LING REN: Oh, yeah.
If you receive a response,
either parent 0 or parent 1
from all your neighbors, then
your job is pretty much done.
But the others have not.
All right.
So you send a message very fast.
They responded to you.
And they are still
working very hard.
OK.
So then we need to use the
technique from the lecture
that's called converge cast.
So everyone will send a
done signal when it is done
and all its children
are also done.
OK.
To do that, I'm going to define
a new variable called searched.
Searched means
someone has responded.
OK.
In this case, w has responded.
I'll put it into
the search the list,
no matter whether it accepts
me as parent or reject.
OK.
Then naturally I need to
define this variable here.
OK.
As a last step, If we search the
list equals my neighbor list,
that means everyone
has responded
and all my children
are done, then
I need a new
variable called done.
That's another list tracking who
has finished and who has not.
OK.
AUDIENCE: So what's
the first one?
LING REN: Say again.
AUDIENCE: What
was the first one?
LING REN: This one?
Searched means
someone has responded
to the search message.
OK.
Done means all its
children are done.
I haven't write how
done is defined.
Give me a minute.
In this case, I'm going to
send my parent a message.
This is the step
of converge cast.
What do I send?
I'm going to send them I'm done.
OK.
Then whenever we
create a message,
we should deal
with that message.
If we receive a message
I'm done, what do we do?
OK.
From w, then we're going
to mark that node as done.
OK.
There's this other point.
So someone has to
initiate the done signal.
That's going to be
our leaves, right.
Because when this
condition check,
they don't have any children.
Their children
list is empty set.
And their done list
is also empty set.
But they're going to send
the I'm done signal first.
And then in the
median nodes, we'll
send a done signal when
all its children are done.
All right.
So this is the
converged cast version.
Only gives us a
termination point
of our spanning tree search.
We haven't count the number
of nodes in the network.
But that's a small modification.
We're just going to include that
number in the I'm done signal.
So then I need to define
another variable called
total that's initialized to 0.
This variable will
attract how many
nodes do I have in
my subtree, including
me and all my children.
Then when I send
the I'm done signal,
I'm going to send this-- sorry.
That's not right way.
When I'm sending
the I'm done signal,
I'm going to send my total
number of offspring with it.
And when I receive,
one of my children
reports that I do
have t children.
I need to increment my
total by that amount.
OK.
I made a mistake again.
Should be total plus 1.
Right.
Because I'm counting
all my children and then
I should include myself.
So that's the
complete algorithm.
Yeah.
One purpose is just to create
a different angle to look
at distributed algorithm.
Usually just draw
that network graphs.
But sometimes it's
helpful to think about how
the code actually works.
OK.
That's all for today.